on a un coup de coeur de du beau gosse
ouais gosses c'est bizarre mais pas mais
en fait on n'a pas vu venir
voilà un coup de coeur pour enora
malagré voilà qui participaient entre
amis semaine dernière de la ce pour la
quatrième fois à fort boyard sur france
2 et voilà qu'ils sont des prix plein la
tronche notamment par voici qui a fait
un barbier vraiment humiliant poil je
les ai eus au téléphone cet après midi
elle n'est pas peiné mais elle est un
marin peut lui milliards soit gras pied
alors le papier sur ce le fait qu'elle
ait pris du poids voilà parce qu'elle
selon le sel a déjà dit même ici
puisqu'elle fait toujours partie de la
famille tpm pl souffrent d'endométriose
comme comme laetitia milot voilà qui
empêche d'avoir des enfants qui essaient
de lourds traitements en plus à un autre
traitement enfin un mois mais voilà qui
sont lourds qui l'empêchent de marcher
son médecin avait déconseillé d'y aller
voilà il y aller quand même parce que
c'était pour une bonne cause pour pour
une association qui lutte contre le
cancer du sein est liée à l'est il ya eu
quelques tweets évidemment elle en veux
pas du tout de suite aux quelques tweets
pour dire qu'elle avait pris un peu de
poids mais voilà elle le serait elle est
très douce en jeu vous saurez mieux même
vous jean-louis parce que franchement
c'est les papiers ça mêle à la fois là
c'est de la connerie parce que le rôle
baissa alors qu'elle est pour une
association ne devait pas y aller elle
se bat pour l'association
on peut ne pas l'aimer mais rehausse
l'attaqué sur le physique et je le dis
en plus même si poursuit nous en mettre
plein la gueule ils sont plutôt drôles
parfois sur leurs briques là là dessus
et ils ont fait voilà comment ils ont
ils ont ils ont fait une boulette parce
que enora elle a été extrêmement peiné
ben je dirais que moi elle m'a fait elle
m'a touché son histoire et nous qui n'y
fit c'est un amour gracia puissant qu'on
est malade on n'a pas envie de se lancer
dans la gueule dans un journal à grand
tirage comme voici titré sur le fait
qu'il ait pris du poids lors qu'ils
aient quelques tweets seront là dessus
et la plupart des gens étaient plus de
la trouvais plutôt sympathique
courageuse et cetera c'est la
grossophobie et c'est aussi une sexiste
ce sera elle sort est un animateur qui
ai pris un peu de poids chez le duo si
ils se répartissent ne serait pas titrer
sur le fait qu'il a pris du poids sur et
le font à chaque fois ils l'ont fait
même sur moi arrêter six ils l'ont fait
après ces moyens soient les bonnes moi
je comprends moi c'est moi sur les
femmes ça me dérange vraiment sur les
mecs franchement on peut se vanner moi
ils m'ont vannes et plein de fois limite
ça m'a fait ça m'a fait marrer parce que
voici je trouve que les légendes à
chaque fois c'est hyper drôle les mais
les gens qui mettent sur les photos
c'est vrai que tu renora j'ai trouvé ça
blessant et il aura surtout c'est
qu'elle ait des problèmes des problèmes
de santé plus d'un sauveur année
mine de rien elle reste toujours quand
même très très séduisante et quand même
voilà une dynamique et on adore a été
hyper contente de faire fort boyard en
plus d'un renard mais c'est le jeu très
triste des médias parce que par exemple
on a aussi attaqué de la même façon luan
pour le même jeu est assez comme ça
voilà c'est affreux c'est comme ça c'est
les réseaux sociaux attention à tous les
rendez moi l on peut faire un boulot
c'est pour dire ça que vous levez la
main tout à l'heure c'était très
important a rappelé qu'il éloigne moi je
trouve l'accord merci oui vraiment non
non c'est pas les réseaux sociaux
bernard des réseaux sociaux c'est un fc
goldorak ces petits pimousse c'est dora
l'exploratrice quitte à pâques donc tu
n'es donc où est la limite unis
sparadrap magnétique est bon je vais
dormir quand même ça va aller c'est à
dire qu'ils sont mis dans une salle avec
des gens ils étaient 3 4 5 est ce qu on
fait ça ils sont mille à dix autour
d'une table pour décider qu'ils allaient
sortir ça mais ça qui est plus gênant
c'est une rédaction
c'est ça il est justement là le problème
c'est que les médias reprennent
longuement négatif des gens sur internet
qui ne te parce que ces produits qui
sont cachés derrière des pseudo c'est
dire que le problème de cette presse-là
de merde alors qu'à un moment donné
quand il est entré dans le stade de
merde moi oh je vous le dis on a été les
premiers à le lire on lit public on lit
causeur ont livré 6 faut arrêter de dire
presse de merde que c'est vraiment joli
et parfois ils ont un second degré qui à
srdjan le patch internet c'est pas
pareil dispositif même si voici nous en
met plein la gueule très souvent moi
j'ai une petite tendresse pour voir si
je vous dis pourquoi pas ce que ça se
fait et imaginer des tests bah moi je
vous le dis ça a été les premiers à
s'intéresser à touche pas à mon poste
mais on est restés droits dans ce 4 mai
ils ont lancé mines dans l émission
faisant un article en disant que cette
élection-là sur le roi de kraft sur le
pagne que le papier sur le papier sur
l'appareil
donc ça paraît quand c'est sur internet
et quand c'est sur papier c'est pas
pareil quand c'est sur internet ça veut
dire que vous allez avoir 1000
commentaires
une personne qui vous dire que vous êtes
grosse une perte nette et kelly se fait
et nora se fait bernard ce fait c'est
pas ça c'est pas sur un commando a
insulté fait insulter se fait ensuite
une grosse queue
et bernard se vend des rafales dans la
tronche non c'est un commentaire que
vous avez vu et c'est pas parce qu'elle
est malade que on doit ne pas l'insulté
et ne pas relever qu'elle est grosse
c'est tout le monde a droit grossir tout
a le droit de maigrir tout le monde fait
ce qu'il veut donc c'est pas parce
qu'elle est malade c'est tout simplement
qu'ils ferment leur gueule et qui
relèvent pas c'est un peu du lias rites
et je trouve moi la sylve et sincère
avec ce genre de père a lui aussi pu le
dire c'est le nous regardons monnaie
s'il vous plaît regardez comme elle est
jolie en plus et non magnifique qu'on
embrasse et n'aura qu'a été extrêmement
touché et peiné pour lui fait des gros
business
non mais c'est un gros bisou à combattre
est fait nous aussi ça elle va jouer au
théâtre
très bientôt je dois la vie prochain on
va financer